كشف مذهل في منشأة للرعاية الصحية
في فينيكس ، قالت قبيلة سان كارلوس
أباتشي إن أحد أعضائها
امرأة تبلغ من العمر 29 عامًا تعيش في حالة غيبوبة
لأكثر من عقد من الزمان كانت
مشربة ولديها طفل أثناء
رعاية Hacienda health care legal
يقول المحللون والمحامي برايان كلايبول
إنه كان هناك تفسير واحد فقط
لما حدث إذا كانت المرأة في
فينيكس في حالة إنباتية
وأنجبت طفلاً ثم تعرضت للاغتصاب
لأنها لم تستطع الموافقة على
علاقة جنسية كورينا سمسم التي تبلغ من
العمر 22 عامًا.  الابنة العجوز هي أيضًا مريضة
تعيش في المنشأة تقول إنها
وأم أخرى أصيبتا بالذعر عندما
سمعا بالحالة التي كنا خائفين جدًا
لأن من يعرف ماذا سيحدث إذا
كان هناك موظف إذا كان أحد
أفراد الأسرة إذا كان شخصًا غريبًا
ليس لدينا أي فكرة عن أن ابنة سيسناس غير قادرة
على المشي وبالكاد قادرة على التحدث بعد
تعرضها لتلف في الدماغ مما جعلها
ضعيفة للغاية ، ماذا قررت
أن تفعل شخصيًا لأم؟  تأكد من أن
ابنتك الموجودة بالداخل آمنة ، فأنا أبقى
هنا على مدار الساعة طوال أيام الأسبوع للتأكد من أنها في
بيئة آمنة أيضًا والمضي قدمًا فقط
لأن الثقة تعرضت للانهيار الشديد
بالنسبة للرئيس التنفيذي للشركة بيل
تيمونز الذي استقال في وقت سابق من هذا
الأسبوع وهاسيندا  أرسل مجلس الرعاية الصحية
بيانًا وصف فيه ما حدث بأنه
موقف مروع للغاية وحالة غير
مسبوقة دون إعطاء
تفاصيل عن الحالة ،
وشهدت شبكة CNN العديد من طرادات الشرطة
المتمركزة في المنشأة خلال النهار
، وتقول شرطة فينيكس إنها
تحقق لكنها لم تقدم أي
تفاصيل إضافية حولها.  أرسلت القضية
يوم الثلاثاء
هذا البيان قائلة إن الشرطة قدمت
مذكرة بحث للحصول على الحمض النووي من
الموظفين الذكور ، وقالت الشركة إنها
ترحب بالتطور في التحقيق ، لكن
سيسانا تقول إن شركة الرعاية الصحية
لم تبلغ أسر المرضى الآخرين حتى
في المنشأة حول
الحادث حتى حوالي خمسة أيام بعد
الولادة وبعد الصغر فقط  كشفت التقارير الإخبارية لـ cal عن
الموقف ، وأعتقد أن
هناك غطاءًا أساسيًا في
مكان ما يحاولون إخفاءه تحتك ،
فبدلاً من أن يكونوا
شفافين ، فهم لا يتسمون
بالشفافية على الإطلاق